hey guys Pete peppers here and this is a
quick video to go along with the
step-by-step guide I just put together
on my website about how to play candy
crush jelly saga on your PC or Mac you
can do it on your laptop or your desktop
computer and all you need to do is get
this Android emulator that's called
BlueStacks so I'll put a link up at the
top to get to you where you can find
those step-by-step and you can follow
the link and do it but this is
BlueStacks calm you can click the
download here here and what it does is
it's a you know it's a it's a it's
called a name an emulator an Android
emulator and what it does is it sets up
your computer so that it can behave as
an Android device and it's a simple
program it doesn't take a all that much
room or anything so I use this myself so
I can say without a doubt that it is
safe and simple and I think that anyone
should be able to follow directions I
wrote out and play on their computer so
once you do once you download it install
it you can see that it's just like a
tablet right here on my on my desktop
this is my laptop so when you first sign
up you'll have to just you know put in
your information for the Play Store and
things like that and then you'll have to
go get your apps you go to the search
function here and you just type in
whatever game you're trying to find at
the bottom it's a search play I've
already got jelly on here but you said
search Play for candy crush jelly it
takes you to the Play Store and once it
loads then you can add the app and so
you know the they might eventually bring
out a Facebook version for candy crush
jelly I haven't heard them say anything
about that and it's been quite a while
so you know it's it's hard to say but
what's nice about having an emulator is
that it will work with all the games
that you can get in the App Store and as
you can see you have tabs up here so you
can actually you know download some
other things if you don't have this yet
it'll have an install button here you'll
hit the install button it'll do it and
then you can open it up and now it's
running just like it would on your phone
or a tablet or anything else most of you
know who played the mobile version that
they don't have a I'm gonna go ahead and
click out of this but you would connect
to Facebook here you know that it
doesn't do landscape but apps that do
have a landscape mode like candy crush
soda
you know they fill the whole screen so
that's that's an added bonus and you
know there's other games like blossom
blast that's a that's a mobile only
title they don't have a Facebook you
version either so you can play all these
different games on here on your laptop
right as it is and like I said you could
get Facebook Messenger or if you want
and put that in another tab and then you
can talk to people that are on Facebook
at the same time while you play in a
different tab so it's a cool it's a cool
thing to have it's easy to install just
follow the link to my guide and follow
the steps and you can have it in play on
your computer like I said it works on
Windows 8.1 it will work on Windows 7 so
you don't have to update the Windows 10
if you want to play on your computer and
you don't have to wait to see if they
come out with a Facebook version or not
any of these other games you can get
them from the store put it on here and
you could play right on your PC Mac
laptop desktop whatever any kind of
computer that you have you'll be able to
play just like you would on an Android
tablet so I hope this helps you out if
you've been wanting to play on your
computer definitely give the video a
like and subscribe to my channel where
you can get so you can get more how to
play videos and help and leave a comment
if you have any questions talk to you